welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and one of visions finale still
inspires new questions for how
wanda's crisis will continue in doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
like what exactly happened to
the boys what is she doing in this
post-credits scene and what was just
unleashed other than apparently all the
dogs in my neighborhood i don't care if
she's friendly this city isn't your dog
park
as a psycho forever on the mephisto
train
i did begin to make the case for how
despite him being a
total no-show in one division the series
absolutely laid the tracks for his
arrival in the future
so that maybe at the bottom of this
ravine the train is crashing into
is actually a temple of doom track
extension
upon which our insanity can stick the
landing and merrily roll along
upon re-watching this finale episode
over and over
discovering new clues each time and
learning more details from the director
and the showrunner
folks a descent into hell or some comic
book
version of hell in multiverse of madness
is looking
even more likely after this finale
that's right folks like a child clinging
to hope that
daddy will show up to my birthday this
year i believe
mephisto is still coming now i know what
you're gonna say
oh look boss found something new to
point out and scream the fist though
hey the difference between me and your
hilarious dicaprio meme is i don't just
point
i leave a trail of treats for you to
find the devil yourself
and you know you hansels and gretels
love it now hop in the oven so in the
final episode the defeated agatha warns
wanda
you have no idea what you've unleashed
implying some darker threat that wanda
as the fully empowered scarlet witch
with the ability to tap into alternate
realities and dimensions
might be in the process of opening the
pandora's box too
and the post-credits scene follows up on
this showing wanda using astral
projection to read the darkhold
until she hears the voices of her sons
billy and tommy
now we still do not know exactly what
these two kids were
if they were just another product of
wanda's hex chaos magic like a lot of
stuff in west view
a why didn't we just see wanda create
them the way she created vision
b why did they rapidly age beyond
wanda's control within
sitcom decade jumps c why are we hearing
their voices now apparently coming from
the dark
holes and d why did wanda in her goodbye
to them
say this boys thanks for choosing me
to be your mom they chose wanda
that's not how natural conception works
the mcu doesn't abide by pixar's soul
logic
some external sentience must have
brought these boys into westview
now i know i have brought this up dozens
of times but just a reminder for anyone
just tuning in
classically in the comics wanda's sons
billy and tommy mysteriously appeared in
her world the same way they do here in
wandavision and these boys were later
revealed to be
unknowingly even them pieces of the soul
of the demon mephisto
assisted by his minions like the witch
agatha harkness in a plot to brainwash
wanda now that exact mephisto backstory
obviously did not play out in one
division
despite clues like fietro aka ralph
under the control of agatha
calling the boys literal demon spawn the
series showrunner jack schaefer said
that when it came to mephisto
grief was enough of a villain for wanda
and director matt shakman on marvin
arden and kevin smith's batman beyonce
similarly laughed off the mephisto
speculation like he's gotta be mephisto
he's got to be some evil marvel guy
everyone was mephisto
everybody was with mister but despite
all this one division did go to
great lengths to at least plant the
seeds of satanic witchcraft and demons
in the mcu
agatha harkness and a coven whose
incantations
are spoken in latin the darkhold the
book of the damned as she calls it
you know what damned refers to folks
souls burning
in hell hell the director even revealed
a deleted scene
in which that rabbit senor scratchy was
revealed to be a disguise for
a monstrous demon so while wandavision
may have punted on a physical mephisto
cameo which i agree
would have been an insane ask the finale
episode
setups for wanda's return and doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
have mephisto's fiery fingerprints all
over them
thank you to skillshare for sponsoring
this video skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
inspiring classes for curious creative
folks
skillshare lets you explore new skills
deepen existing passions and get lost in
creativity skillshare offers classes
designed for
real life you can learn and grow with
short classes that fit any schedule they
have classes and topics new rockstars
fans will enjoy like animation film and
music production
one of their film and video classes that
looks really cool is how to make dope
low budget films
taught by filmmaker julian clepper the
film covers everything from writing on a
budget to casting hiring a crew shooting
the film and editing no matter what 2021
brings you spend it creating something
meaningful with skillshare's online
classes skillshare is curated
specifically for learning
there are no ads and they're always
launching new premium classes so that
you can stay focused and follow wherever
your creativity takes you
and it's less than ten dollars a month
with an annual subscription and the
first 1000 of our subscribers to click
the link in the description will get a
free trial of premium membership so that
you can explore your creativity
wanda uses astral projection a nod to
doctor strange using this same kind of
spell to study more spell books as he
sleeps
however every other character we have
seen use astral projection in the mcu
must leave their physical body behind as
it is incapacitated a soul can only be
active in one place
at a time that's the rule steven strange
the several times he does this in doctor
strange
the ancient one when she lays dying on
the operating table
bruce banner leaving his hulk body
sleeping in endgame
so for wanda to be awake during her
astral projection
two souls suggests that she might
already be pairing with
an alternate reality version of herself
controlling both
why not just flip through the dark hole
herself it is just a book well maybe
she's using this astral projected form
to keep any curses embedded in that
book's pages from harming her physical
body now cracking open this old book its
illustrations show a form of the
prophecy
scarlet witch outlined in a hexagon
which we can surmise from the
show is basically the geometric shape a
new reality takes
and then on the opposing page we see a
series of overlapping circles
all this could be depicting the scarlet
witch as a nexus being has control over
creating a reality
and can tap into other alternate
pre-existing realities
and now she could be using the dark hole
to peer into those alternate realities
why
looking for one reality in which her
children
exist very similar to how dr strange
using the time stone looked into various
alternate futures for one victorious one
the scene even underlines the doctor
strange parallel by playing the doctor
strange theme during this
and now wanda has found her kids but
why are these boys crying out for help
think about it if they were just billy
and tommy
living their alternate lives undisturbed
why are they now under duress
calling for some ultimate reality mommy
to come save them
these cries of help must be bait for
wanda
the way agatha used the boys as bait in
the finale
a siren call from the book of the damned
designed to lure the scarlet witch
into a dimension where she thinks she'll
find her kids
when she gets there she only finds the
foreign source of their arrival to west
view
the reason they chose her the
unleashed threat a satanic demon
possessing witch warned her about
mephisto since this series loved its
wizard of oz references
think of the boy's cries here as the
cries for dorothy from her loved one
back home which is actually a deceptive
taunt
where are you it's me
i'm here
[Music]
and marvel is giving us an auntie and
mephisto by the way it always freaked me
out how she turns to look
at us there as if she could do this to
us watching at any time
now to many of you multiverse of madness
looks like it could just be setting up
the scarlet witch as the villain of that
story but i really think this is more
complicated than that that wanda is not
a villain but rather just
a misunderstood kind of patient chasing
a rabbit down a hole
rupturing universes as she goes in need
of a
physician's healing powers we needed the
series of wandevision to give us the
emotional underpinnings of this madness
but now that we know what's going on
inside wanda's head let the madness
begin
support our madness here at new
rockstars by checking out one of our
many great merch options at new
rockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow new rockstars subscribe to
the rockstars for everything marvel
thank you for watching my pretties
[Music]
you